welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for the second day of our seventh
annual neuroscience event we start today
with the session on the perspectives on
neuropsychiatric disorders
neuropsychiatric disorders are prevalent
in society yet our understanding of the
biological basis of these disorders is
severely limited in today's session we
will hear from some of its hot
scientific experts in the field who have
made great strides towards improving our
understanding of the underlying
mechanisms of dysfunction in these
disorders they will describe their novel
theories and approaches which have
allowed them to gain new insight into
the myriad of factors that contribute to
the disease state neural social
molecular and computational
considerations drive forward not only
improved understanding of
neuropsychiatric disorders but also
better prevention and therapeutic
avenues for them it's an honor and a
pleasure to introduce our keynote
speaker for this session dr. andreas
meyer Lindenberg will be presenting on
the environmental risk mechanisms for
psychiatric disorders
professor Meyer Lindenberg is the
director of the central institute of
mental health in Mannheim Germany as
well as the medical director of the
department of psychiatry and
psychotherapy there he is also a
professor and chairman of psychiatry and
psychotherapy at the University of
Heidelberg in Heidelberg Germany he is
board-certified in psychiatry
psychotherapy and neurology for a
complete biography on our speaker please
visit the biography tab at the top of
your screen my name is Judy O'Rourke and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots laggards is the leading scientific
social networking website and producer
of educational virtual events and
webinars before we begin I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting questions
during the presentation simply click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box our
speaker will respond to
questions following his presentation
this presentation is educational and
thus offers free continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming professor andreas
Meyer Lindenberg thank you very much
Julie I'm pleased to be virtually with
you and talk about environmental risk
mechanisms for psychiatric disorders the
reason we might be interested in a topic
like that I guess becomes clear if you
look at the burden that mental disorders
entail
this is a European studies they're
similar experiences around the world but
if you look at the European number as
you can see at the bottom there that
common psychiatric disorders such as
mood disorders depression but also
psychotic disorders and anxiety
disorders have a tremendous cost to
society which amounts to more than a
hundred thousand million euros a year
for mood disorders a burden that is much
much higher than that for other brain
disorders and in combination about as
high as that for a common somatic
disorder so we have a huge problem here
we have disorders that are very
prevalent and they're very severe and so
in order to try and fix this the ideal
medical response would indeed be
prevention we would try to prevent those
disorders from ever happening if you
bring neuroscience into that
conversation that motivates a strategy
in which she would like to analyze cause
the risk factors what is meant by this
is that you would like to go away from a
patient with the manifest illness such
as schizophrenia or a depression towards
the factors that we know are causally
related to increase that person's risk
which in every illness you can decompose
into genetic factors and environmental
factors and the interactions between the
two and the reason we would like to
that is that you go in time prior to the
manifestation of the earnest which might
enable you to prevent them from ever
happening now many genes in many
environmental risk factors have been
found our research and the topic of my
talk today will not be in finding new
genetic and environmental risk factors
it will be about taking genes and
environmental exposures that we already
know about and ask the questions how are
they working what's happening in the
brain of someone who carries a gene is a
question we often ask but today will be
more focused on the question what
happens in the brain of someone who has
been exposed to an environmental risk
also resilience factors and how does
this increase or decrease that person's
risk to become ill the hope is that that
will give us insights into the
neurobiology of risk and resilience that
will enable us to intervene very early
or perhaps even to prevent these
illnesses from happening and as I said
many of these environmental risk factors
are well known this is a overview slide
from a paper and Jim one Austin in which
he was looking at evidence related to
schizophrenia and you can see that
there's a broad variety of risk factors
that are shown here all of which have
been proven to be causal for
schizophrenia risk with a very high
degree of certainty a much higher off
than the certainty that given genes have
fur being associated with a mental
disorder and of those many risk factors
today we are going to focus on a few
that have to do with the social
environment the reason we're doing that
is shown in this study this is a study
in which the authors compiled a lot of
evidence on if you were lifestyle
factors things that relate to people's
behaviors that are known to be important
for health because they prolong lifespan
they're good
for your survival so all of those things
that you see here are good for your
survival but the point of the paper
wasn't that the point of the paper was
to bring them on a common scale - so you
can compare their impact this court
effect size is what you see in the top
here and if you go down and read your
way up you can see that a bunch of
things that are often discussed is being
important for health however not having
that big an impact so for example being
lean versus being obese has a highly
significant effect but the effect is
around 0.2 which is a relatively small
effect size physical activity isn't much
better if you go up you can see that not
drinking or smoking that gets higher but
the one thing that in humans has a large
effect on survival and therefore health
is the question of whether you have or
you don't have a supportive social
environment if you have people who
ideally love you but also people who
know you by name or do you a favor will
help you in everyday life and the size
of this supportive social network is
crucially related with health with
survival and that applies of course even
more so to mental disorders in which the
social domain is critical so based on
that today I want to talk to you about
three established environmental risk
factors for schizophrenia that you see
their social status migration and
urbanist city of being born in cities
and I will ask the question of how do
they work in brain and I will argue that
they represent specific kinds of social
stress that a heart process for brain
that's already ordered for example by
background genetic risk which is very
important for several of the mental
disorders we'll be touching on today and
I'm gonna start us off with social
economic status this is a paper from
2016 that I think many of you will have
read
the reason I think that is said it was
one of the most highly discussed papers
of that entire year what happened in
this papers that researchers compiled a
very large data set about income in the
United States and related it to expected
lifespan and you see here separately for
men and women that at the very lowest
income percentiles you have some
deviations from non-linearity it
probably has to do with access to health
care and lifestyle factors but then you
get into this very striking linear
increase the more you make the longer
you live and even at the very highest
percentiles which in the US are
households with income around two
million you still see if you go up one
percent you still have an increase of
your lifespan of several weeks or month
and the total difference between the
poorest and the wealthiest so I should
probably say the least
earning the most earning households is
actually bigger than the lifespan impact
of cancer as a disease category
altogether it's a very large effect that
had been shown before but not in this
precision in such a large data set and
it means that your status is related to
lifespan and that is something that we
don't only see in humans we see it in
all animals that have a social hierarchy
which is the vast majority of animals
that do have social interactions they
tend to show hierarchies and it
therefore becomes a very interesting
question to ask how are social
hierarchies mapped in the human brain
and to look at that a bunch of years
back we did a functional imaging study
that you should see schematically here
what we did here is tell people that we
would do a rewarded game with them in an
fMRI scanner which allowed us to look at
brain activity in this case the game was
that the subjects had to watch a blue
circle in the middle of
screen which turned green at some point
they had to press a button and when they
did that within a short time span if
they did it rapidly enough they would be
rewarded with money and that money they
got to get home take home in the end
which means that they were highly
motivated to do that to actually do play
this game well then we told people
participants that together with them
there were two other participants also
playing that game and we tested
participants reaction time before and we
tore participants that their reaction
time was in the middle of this group of
three year we will give them two stars
but there was one other player who had
three stars because was a faster and
another one who slower and who got one
star and we told them that whenever they
played one of the other two would also
play and they could see whether they
want money or not but they shouldn't
think that it was an antagonistic game
was the competition whether they got
their money only depended on their own
reaction time but we said you can see
how the other ones are playing and
sometimes to show you where you stand in
the ranking based on how much money you
want in this game so in other words what
we did here is establish a pseudo
hierarchy with those pseudo military
star symbols three to one and then ask
how the brain processes the hierarchy
and of course a lot happens in the brain
when you're playing a game you're
waiting to press a button you press the
button you waiting whether you get
reward all of that but on the first
approximation we didn't look at all of
that what we did is before each round
you can see there in the red circle
we showed which of the two other players
was playing the one with three stars
which was above in the hierarchy or the
one of the one stars was below and then
asked is there a differential signal in
human brain for seeing the someone above
you in the hierarchy with the three star
or below you in the hierarchy and there
won't be the one star and you could
argue maybe there shouldn't be any
difference between after all that
hierarchy was
brand-new it wasn't relevant to how much
money they got we told them not to
attend to these people in fact these
people didn't even exist we told that to
the subjects only after the experiment
the reason they didn't exist is that we
know from previous evidence that you can
extract a lot of information about
people's status from their pictures by
attending to things such as age gender
dress and so on so basically before
experiment we made a picture of the
subject and then we found pictures of
two other people who were very similar a
similar race similar age similar sex ins
on to control for these factors so the
question now is is there signal in brain
for social superior which would be a
three star player and the answer is
there's an enormous signal in brain when
that happens which encompasses the
entire visual spatial attention system
ventral striatum hippocampus to also
letter prefrontal cortex basically a lot
of brain areas that are related to
attentional resources were active more
active when you saw social superior next
question which brain areas are more
active when you socially see a social
inferior the answer there was very clear
as well there were none there wasn't
even a single bit and the human brain
was more active to seeing a socially
inferior which means that social
hierarchies work by shifting your
attention towards the social superior in
the room and there's no good behaved
Oriole evidence to back that up as well
so the processing of social hierarchy in
human brain is relatively simple now in
the next step we did something in
addition we would Pete at the experiment
with a new group but with a different
game just to be sure that the specific
game wasn't important and then we told
people
well you're 2 stars but maybe you get
better during the game and then you
could be a 3 star player or if you're
really bad you could fall back into the
1 star position so in other words
what we did is we made the hierarchy
unstable and we did that because we know
from previous work that if you're in an
instable hierarchy losing your position
is especially stressful and so when we
repeated the experiment in the unstable
condition we found again the same prayer
at brain areas active when you see
superior again we found no brain areas
active when you're in inferior but now
we found specific brain areas which were
only active in the unstable condition so
those are ones that we should attend to
if we're interested in the health
effects of hierarchy and prevention and
those brain areas were amygdala which
you see on the right which is a critical
signaling structure for emotion and also
adversity and amygdala was active more
in people who paid more attention to
hierarchies to whom they're in Iraq the
position was more important and also
when they were about to lose their
hierarchical position and the other
brain region you see there on the left
in red that's an area the medial
prefrontal cortex that we know and we're
gonna talk more about this as a
regulatory function with regard to
amygdala so those two are two brain
structures that we should bear in mind
and I'm going to show you another
example Forest factor next so you can
see more of that circuit and that other
risk factor I would like to talk about
is urban a city of being born in a city
if you are born in a city your risk of
schizophrenia goes way up goes up by Ron
triple by 300% which is the biggest
known environmental risk factor for that
very debilitating disorder if you
currently live in a city your risk for
depression for schizophrenia doesn't go
up much more but what goes up for people
who currently live in big cities is the
risk for depression and anxiety
disorders which go up around the world
by a factor of around four
percent thirty to forty to fifty percent
on average so being in a city currently
increases your risk for depression and
anxiety and being born in the city
really increases your risk for
schizophrenia but that finding which has
been known for over half a century now
has created a lot of studies to figure
out is this really causal or is being
born a city a proxy for something else
and the answer seems to be yes it is in
some sense causal and the other question
is why why would that be so how does
that work
and one common idea that people had is
that that might be related to social
factors in series that interactions in
cities are somewhat more stressful so to
test this idea a few years back we did
an experiment to try and look at whether
there is indeed an impact on city living
on social stress so to do that we used a
variant of a stress test called the Tia
social stress task and that variant was
developed by a colleague who was in
Canada at the time and adapted for
imaging the basic idea of these tasks is
that you're doing something stressful in
front of an audience and given the
impression that the audience disapproves
of your performance in this case people
are asked to do mental health
sorry mental arithmetic like the
equation you see up there and they were
also given the impression that they were
doing poorly and as you can see on the
top right panel that is stressful
because you can see that the stress
hormone cortisol goes up and of course
also after the experiment told people
about that experimental manipulation and
they told us that they experience that
is very stressful so if you do this in
imaging and compare it to condition in
which you also have to do cognitive
tasks but aren't stressed you can see a
bunch of brain areas which are
differentially active during social
stress you can see some of them in the
brain slices in the bottom here and that
was known so this is the soldier
stress brain network which is quite
extensive but we now had a more specific
question you are asking off those brain
areas that are differentially active
when you're stressed
are there any that are related to the
size of the city you currently live in
and that would be by the evidence we
have just discussed relevant for
depression and anxiety disorder and or
other any related to the site of the
city when you were born and that would
be interesting for schizophrenia
and we got a relatively clear answer for
both of those questions so if you take
city living first the brain area that
reacts during social stress to the size
of your current city environment is
amygdala again which doesn't react much
when you live in a rural area and it
reacts a little bit when you live in a
smaller town reacts a lot when you live
in a big city and and the law of Roth as
you can see a replication that we did in
this initial publication with a
different sample this has now been
replicated in several other samples as
well so the more the bigger the city you
live and the more your amygdala reacts
and that makes sense because as we have
just discussed previously with regard to
social status amygdala has the function
of a danger sensor as you can see there
on the top left with the famous drawing
with a snake and so hyper reactive
amygdala is something that we find
associated with depression and anxiety
disorders which are exactly those
disorders that you find increased in
people currently living in a big cities
that suggests that we have a mechanism
here that does indeed link social stress
to risk for these mental disorders in
city life
now what about schizophrenia so it's the
question about urban birth and that
highlighted the area that you see on the
left
both for the original and the
replication study in the initial paper
that's again part of the media
prefrontal cortex that's a part of the
cingulate gyrus and we call this peri
cingulate cortex because it is close to
the genu of the corpus callosum just
adjacent to it that was the brain area
related to being born and growing up in
a big city in your first years of life
and that's an interesting brain area
with regard to amygdala because in a
previous range of studies done of the
National Institutes of mental health
under the direction of Danny Weinberger
we looked at genes that show gene
environment interactions other genes in
the SIRT onin system and basically the
risk variants don't have a lot of impact
if you are not exposed to environmental
adversity but if a lot of bad things
happen to you during especially
childhood then the risk for psychiatric
phenotype such as depression also
aggression goes up and studying the
effects of those genes and brain we
found that they highlighted that xx ER
we've just seen between the pair each
annual cingulate cortex and amygdala and
so we've come to think of those two
brain areas which are linked in a
feedback loop as a circuit for gene
environment interaction and so it's very
intriguing to see that circuit show up
by looking at a social risk factor such
as urban birth now the bad news for city
dwellers don't stop at function we also
found that being born in the city
impacts your brains structure it impacts
the brain structure in the dorsolateral
prefrontal cortex as what you see on the
left and in men also impacts that brain
structure we've just discussed peri
genuine cingulate cortex these two brain
structures were smaller in the urban
born now that of course
is the question of how does that work
what are the causes of these findings in
brain especially if as we've said the
offset we would like to do prevention we
would like to stop the city environment
from being deleterious with regard to
mental health and if we want to do that
we need to be quick we have an urgent
problem because urbanization is rapidly
proceeding it used to be of course that
throughout human history most people
lived in rural circumstances just a few
years back around 2011 that mankind
crossed the threshold as you can see on
the right panel here when more people
live in the city than in the country and
by 2050 it's going to be two thirds of
people who live in big cities a process
not driven so much by Europe and North
America
which are very urbanized already but
especially by Asia and by China in which
many many people are getting and being
urbanized so if you think back about
what we said the beginning about the
risk increase that city living in city
birth gives you with regard to mental
disorders you need to be finding out
ideas of what could you change in the
urban environment to make it better for
mental health and to do that we've
started a study a few years back now
which is still ongoing which is trying
to find some answers to this problem and
what we did in this study is to use
smart phones with GPS signal enabled to
track people in cities so we knew during
the work week that such a session
usually entails where in the city or in
the countryside they currently are and
we use that phone to ask them how they
are doing we use a method called monitor
ecological momentary assessment which
means that several times through the day
the phone will vibrate and people were
then asked to tell us what
the mood is with the stress level is
whether they're with other people or
alone what they're doing these kinds of
questions so we know how they've been
feeling and we're in the city they've
been and together with collaborators in
the study from the University of
Heidelberg we have made a lot of maps
that show us potentially relevant
aspects of urban life so we have maps of
green space we have maps of traffic
patterns we have maps of socioeconomic
status ethnic contributions to who lives
in that part of town and so on so we
collect data on people's experiences in
the city in that social Geographic
context if you will and after that week
we study their brain using the
techniques I've just introduced to you
and that has the advantage that we don't
have to wait for these people to get
sick to have a mental illness or not we
can look in their brain and find a
quantitative measure that we think is
related to risk and when the study
started nature in a editorial related to
the topic I made this picture of this
idea and you can see someone standing
there next to a tree who is relaxed or
someone who's annoyed because it's close
to a road and someone lonely next to a
skyscraper and of course it isn't quite
as simple as that figure would suggest
but that's the general idea who would
like to understand who fears how and
what circumstances in which of the
context the rivers and cities are to
blame for it with the goal of maybe
doing something about it and I would
like to highlight one especially salient
factor in cities that we have found has
a big impact on well-being and that is
nature experience in cities urban green
space this is a paper done by
collaborators in Stanford which looked
at a group of people who are the told to
go in the countryside or
go to the city and they used a method
called material spin labeling which
allows you to a very nicely measure rain
blood flow before and after that
intervention and you can see on the left
that that again hit that experimental
manipulation hit that area and the
parish on your singular cortex and they
found that that change in paradigm a
singlet cortex mediated a striking
improvement in those people's well-being
even the cognitive function they were
doing quite a lot better with regard to
mood and also with regard to executive
cognition just by virtue of the short
walk highlighting both the benefits of
being supposed to nature and the
benefits of that or the the role of that
specific brain area now that is a
controlled experiment in our study we
can see whether the same thing happens
in the natural environment and the
answer is that the same thing happens so
this is looking at people moving freely
in the city or in the country and you
can see that practically everyone feels
better when they are exposed tomorrow
urban green space so the xxxx you see
open green space density on the left on
the y axis you can see all the feeling
and all of almost all of those lines are
pointing up so the more green space they
better they fear but of interest the
slope of those lines is very different
so some people benefit a lot from urban
green space some people benefit only a
little and that green space gain if you
will is an interesting thing that you
can then interrogate with regard to
what's going on in brain and also the
circumstances of those people and what
we found is that those people who
benefit most from being exposed to urban
green space are people who are at risk
for mental illness and who are deficient
in regulating their emotions in an
emotion regular
Tass they were deficient in recruiting
especially dorsolateral prefrontal
cortex to inhibit the emotional response
and so the ideas that urban green space
provides the regulatory mechanism for
them that they cannot access on their
own and in agreement with that idea we
find that these people also show some
other risk factors for mental illness
for example they have a higher tendency
to react anxiously when stressed
something that's called harm avoidance
or also neuroticism and that was also
related to the degree in which their
brain reacted this way and we then asked
where in the city are those people as
they go around the day do they cluster
in certain aspects of the city and what
we found as you can see that on the
lower panel of grass at the clustered in
a part of the city which is marked by a
red arrow sorry a red circle which is a
high risk area that's an area of high
psychiatric risk social deprivation
several risk factors come together here
this is where those people habitually
are and this is an area with especially
little Bourbon green space it suggests
that if you only have a given number of
trees to distribute if you want to
actually do prevention you can do that
targeted by targeting your prevention
efforts of those parts of town which
show high deprivation and low green
space which is an interesting aspect
from the point of view of social
psychiatry and prevent now I've talked
to you about social status and cities I
would like to give you one last example
of risk factor which also brings
together some of those mechanism and
that example is migration after being
born a city the second strongest risk
factor for schizophrenia is whether or
not you live in the city you have been
born in so whether or not you're
first-generation migrant or
even whether your parent was the first
generation migrant and that increases
your risk for schizophrenia to something
around 270 280 or in the case of the
second generation migrant a little
higher even 300 percent and you can
already tell from the fact that the
second generation migrants address that
this doesn't have anything to do with
pre migratory factors how is your life
in your country of origin and also not
with the stress of migrating this
estimate was the post migratory phase
has to do with living in a country whose
interactions with social structure is
different from the one of your country
of birth if you're first-generation
migrant are different from the one that
still characterized the family you were
brought up in in the case of the second
generation migrants so we actually do a
lot of work with refugees these days and
in refugees of course you have
additional problems that come through
hardship in the country they were
displaced from and also during their
flights but we're talking about now
isn't about that this is about looking
at the post migratory phase and of
course this is something very different
from being born in a city but these two
things have that in common that they
increase the risk for the same
psychiatric disorder similarity so you
can now use neuroscience to us with a
simple question okay if you look in
brain is the effect of these two risk
factors very similar or is it very
different if it is very similar you've
learned something and in the other case
as well so we performed an experiment
adapted to the migrant situation in
which we were again using a social
stress paradigm to look at the reaction
of a group of second-generation migrant
and match non migrants in this case in
our home country of Germany and what we
found is that we looked at the social
stress response the impact on brain was
exactly the same as the one that we
found in the urban boards again that
area of Perry genja cingulate court
that is hyper reactive in migrants and
brain areas that are linked to it we
talked about amygdala before but here I
would like to highlight one other brain
area that you can see in penisy and that
is called ventral striatum and that is
interesting because the ventral striatum
is a brain area which is linked to the
emergence of psychosis in a very similar
way that type of reactive amygdala is
linked to the emergence of depression
and anxiety disorder and the way this
works is that we know from
groundbreaking work about insurance that
a dopamine signal in brain is critical
for indicating to the brain important
event salient events in the environment
and therefore triggers a response where
you attend to these important events and
in schizophrenia as shown here elegans
started by granamyr and co-workers this
response is dysregulated you have more
response to irrelevant stimuli and that
is probably what leads you down the way
to psychosis because you're constantly
having the impression something
important is going on because that
salience systems chaotically up
regulated but there isn't actually
anything going on but you feel compared
to attend to this and that leads you on
the road to delusions for example so in
the executive venture Australia response
is a final pathway find a path a
physiological pathway on the way to
psychosis similar to what a hyper
reactive amygdala does as a final common
pathway on the road to depression
anxiety disorders now this suggests that
in migrants when they are socially
stressed they should release more
dopamine interest Rider and that is
something actually found in a
collaborative study with colleagues in
Canada and the UK which use pet together
with the social stress task of the kind
of shown you here to find that
non-immigrants when social stress
release dopamine - you can see that in
the pan on the left that'll be known but
immigrants when socially stressed
release a lot more at much much stronger
dopamine release indicating that in fact
there might be a dysregulation of the
doorman respond to social stress that
puts immigrants at an increased risk for
psychosis and you can see this again in
the scatterplot here and not only the
release of dopamine but also the
synthesis of dopamine is increased in
that population and just as immigrants
had the same functional impact that the
Erb born had they also had a very very
similar structural impact which again
was situated in the medial prefrontal
cortex especially in men as you can see
here in this publication so both in
structure and function the impact of
migration and of urban isset e were very
similar and also the third risk factor
that I talked to you about links their
social status I've already talked to you
about a functional imaging data which in
this slide you can see on the lower
right but at a similar time a study was
done by a martyr Aryan colleagues in
which people met perceived social status
on a ladder that you can see here on
brain structure and they again found
that part on peri Jane your singlet
cortex being impacted to your perceived
social standing in the Society's
hierarchy this is something we can
replicate in all migrants but then we
can add one interesting facet to it
which is that in migrants and especially
in refugees there's often a change
between the social status when they were
born the social cells of the parents and
the ones that they have attained as a
dollars fear because they have moved for
economic opportunity so they have
improved the social status or for
refugees of they've been the place and
the status has suffered and if we look
at that interaction between social
standing now at birth
it again maps on the para general
singular cortex you can see that here
and it is actually mediated by by the
impact of that brain area by virtue of
chronic stress so we can see this link
between chronic social stress that
specific brain area and the third risk
factor that I've talked to you about
status so if we put all of that together
in a model it suggests that ethnic
minority stands but the same would
happen to birth through social
adversities and an interaction with
genetic and epigenetic factors leads to
a sensation in a specific brain area and
a specific system that the brain area
regulates which then if acute stress
hits you in adulthood leads to the
manifestation of psychosis by virtue of
this regulation of the dopamine response
now unfortunately only of time to talk
about the three specific risk factor
would just like to point out to you that
there many other childhood adversity
sexual misconduct there's poverty things
like that and they also impact the brain
in various ways but they are tended to
converge on the area of the paradigm
your cingulate cortex again which we
have come to think of in some way now as
the centerpiece shown here in blue of a
sakura tree that mediates environmental
risk and that's also impacted on
although that hasn't been much in the
focus of today's talk by genetic risk
factors was a convergent risk system now
having that and returning to the topic
of our presentation how can we use that
to improve people's well-being how can
we use that to improve resilience
now the first resilience factor that you
should probably ask for is social
interactions if the social network is
good for you if social stress is bad for
you is there a positive effect of the
size of the social network on that sub-q
'try and it turns out that there is such
a study from 2010 in
the researchers showed the more friends
you have the bigger your social network
is the bigger issue amygdala and
actually also part of the prefrontal
cortex and that applies not only to real
friends even applies but although the
week of fashion to people you only know
virtually - through Facebook for example
other social networks so more people are
good for you in the sense that motivates
a great interest that we are having a
lot of people having actually looking at
what do these social interactions do to
the brain and to do that we are using a
method called hyper scanning which uses
two fMRI scanners one subject in each of
those scanners and studies both of them
why they interact through an
audio-visual uplink with each other and
this has been a thorny analysis problem
to try and quantify how this information
flow from which part of one person's
brain through the other person's brain
during their interaction but this is
something that we and others have been
working on we now think we have a
relatively good idea on how we can
analyze these complicated datasets to
look at various ways of social
interaction you can look at something
very simple shown on top here this is
something called joint attention where
someone looks where that other person is
looking at that's very simple form of if
you will social cooperation that's
important in development for helping
children to develop more complicated
capabilities and social cognition such
as the theory of mind but you can also
look at interactions shown below in
which you're not just doing that but
you're actually trying to achieve a
common goal or to establish cooperation
or try to have an antagonistic
interaction in which you were trying to
win something from another purse and the
final point I would like to make is
using this method we looked at the
interaction between immigrants and
normal immigrants between migrants and
hosts and what we found in the study
is that the brain systems that support
the social interactions between migrants
and non migrants are the same that
support interactions between groups of
non migrants or groups of migrants
talking to one another and it
prominently includes as you can see on
the left again those parts of the medial
prefrontal cortex in addition to some
other brain areas important to social
cognition such as the temporal parietal
Junction but if you then look at how
successful the interaction is and you
can look at that in a brain way by
looking at neuron coupling how much of
the information from one brain to
another gets over then how efficient the
other couple you find that if migrants
are not magaz interact there's no
difference for simpler forms of
interaction but if you have an
interaction that involves trust then the
neural coupling and you can see that on
the left on the right is completely
predicted by cultural distance the
closer the two people are culturally the
better the interaction works on the
level of brain and conversely and this
is I think a very interesting finding
for digging deeper and this is something
that we're now doing a bunch of projects
into those interactions between migrants
and trolls which have become a major
societal topic in my country as perhaps
there are in yours and need to be
studied not just from the point of view
of the migrants and theories which is
what we have been focused on but also
with a view of what do these kinds of
interactions - with the host especially
if they haven't been exposed to migrants
a lot in the past so in summary what
I've tried to show you is a set of
studies looking at a range of risk
factors associated with severe mental
disorders and the point wasn't so much
about those specific exporters who could
have looked at totally different ones
I've shown you some examples we could
have looked at genes but the points that
you can use neuroscience to define brain
systems of risk and that those brain
systems of risk and we've discussed this
in the context of the urban SAT effect
might give you
a clue on how to prevent and intervene
in these common and severe disorders in
the future with that let me thank the
funders of this work what you can see in
the left and my co-workers in my lab
which you can see on the right which
have been instrumental in this work and
thank you very much for your attention
thank you dr. Maier Lindenberg for that
informative presentation I would like to
pose some audience questions to you
first one is what about the relation
between genetic risk for mental
disorders and the environmental factors
you talked about that's an excellent
question many psychiatric disorders have
a large genetic contribution
schizophrenia for example genetic
contribution is like 70 to 80 percent
and others not depression the genetic
contribution is only about a third but
it's always there so the question is how
do genes and environment interact and
the answer is interestingly that genes
tend to hit that same circus both common
genetic variants for example si si
anyone see and rare variants copy number
variants in our hands as in those of
many other labs around the world tend to
hit similar structures what they would
predict in terms of risk is that you
already carry certain risk dreams you
might be more at risk for environmental
exposure by virtue of an impact on the
same circuit and the same applies for
resilience genes if you have a gene that
improves the function of that circuit it
might also improve your resilience
against that risk factor so there's a
dynamic interplay we know that from
epidemiology but we can map it to the
brain just as we can map the
environmental effects on the brain thank
you next is what can people do to reduce
their risk in cities yeah that's a good
question if you hear these numbers
schizophrenia risk goes up by tripper
depression risk goes up at 40% and the
thing that you obviously usually can't
do is just move out of the city because
it would get very crowded in the
countryside
because we've seen that more people live
I live in cities now than in the
countryside it's also also not feasible
some things that you can do relate to
the resilience factors we've already
found for example attending to green
space and very little is actually enough
you don't have to take a long hike to
Central Park it's quite enough to
actually just look over the degree of
mindfulness auditory appears to have a
measurable effect there's basic
mechanisms of stress resilience things
like mindfulness time planning these
things are often useful and so there's a
lot that you can do in the city
environment to make it better we're
currently looking at other effects
address for example traffic how do you
get from A to B things that relate to
social interactions but there would be
some simple suggestions in the event
that you're unlucky enough to live in a
city and county immediately move out oh
thank you any other questions that were
submitted today for our speaker will be
followed up via email thank you again
dr. Maier Lindenberg for your
presentation and thank you lab roads for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that this webcast will be
available for on-demand viewing through
June 14 2019 that's all for now thanks
for joining us and we'll see you next
time bye-bye